من ساعات الصباح الاولى واسمها الامير
هاري متصدر العناوين والسبب اجدد حلقات
الدراما الجديد للجديده للامير لليوم كان
مقرر انه يتم استجوابه امام المحكمه
العليا في بريطانيا ووقوفه في منصه الشهود
فالامير واحد من بين مئه شخصيه مشهوره
رافعين دعوه ضد ميرور جروب نيوزبير او
نيوز وهي ومن المؤسسه اللي بتصدر صحيفه
ديلي ميرير
وبيتهموها بانها عمله قرص على هواتفهم بين
سنه سته وتسعين
2010 وحصلت على معلومات تم نشرها على نطاق
واسع وبكده هذه راح يكون اول فرد رفيع من
العائله المالكه البريطانيه بيوقف امام
محكمه من 130 سنه المؤسسه الاعلاميه
اعترفت انها قرصنه هاتف الامير
سابقان يعني وقالت انه بقدر يطلب انه هو
يقدر تحديدا الامير فعلا عن اللي سووه
اطلب تعويض ماده على هذا الموضوع لكنهم
انكروا التهم الثانيه هاري ما راح يوقف
لوحده امام المحكمه لانه جاري مع العيله
المالكه فالمؤسسه الاعلاميه بتقول انه
مصدر كثير من هذه المعلومات هو العيله
المالكه والعاملين فيها طيب من لندن معنا
من امام المحكمه مراسل العربيه مصطفى زارو
اهلا فيك معنا مصطفى طبعا الامير هاري هو
واحد من الشخصيات في هذه القضيه اللي يعني
فيها كثير من الاسماء الشهيره هل نعرف مين
اللي حنشوفهم في المحكمه
ان حقيقه هناك ممثلون ربما اقل شهره من
اولئك الذين تم نشر اسمائهم يعني وفي
صدارهم
ورثت مايكل جورج مايكل المغني الشهير ايضا
فيما يتعلق بصديق المغني
بالاضافه الى ممثلين وايضا وكوميديين لكن
الاسماء التي تم اختيارها هي ثلاثه فقط
الى جانب
الامير هاري وبالتالي يعني الكل سيتابع
هذه التغطيه الاعلاميه
لهذه المحاكمه الفريده من نوعها كنا نتوقع
ان يحضر الامير هاري في جلسه الاستماع
اليوم لكن غاب عنها بعد ان قال ممثل ممثله
المحامي شربون بان الامير هاري وصل متاخرا
من لوس انجلوس امس وبسب حضوره حفل عيد
ميلاد ابنته وبالتالي كان هناك توقعات بان
البيانات الافتتاحيه من كلا الجانبين هيئه
الدفاع وهيئه الادعاء ستطلب يوم كامل لكن
بالطبع محامو صحيفه الميرور يعني كانوا
قلقين جدا لانهم خسروا فرصه استجواب
الاميره اليوم ولكن القاضي
قال بان سيمنح الوقت
لفريق يعني
الدفاع
لصحيفه الميرو وهذا يعني بان سيتم استجواب
الامير هاري ليوم ونصف اليوم يعني غدا
وربما نصف يوم الاربعاء سيكون تحت ضغط
الاسئله
المحققين لصحيفه
نحن الان يعني ربما بنهايه اليوم الاول
لهذه الجلسه كان يفترض ان تنتهي الساعه
الرابعه يعني قبل تقريبا 25 دقيقه لكن
يبدو ان هناك المزيد من من تقديم الادله
والكلمه
محامي سريع بس محامي صحيفه
سريعا كيف رده فعل الناس هل متعاطفين معهم
في هذه القضيه
ان حقيقه
الامير هذه الشخصيه يعني مثيره يعني اغلب
اولئك الذين يدعمونهم من فئات عموريه
شبابيه وبالتالي ربما دعم الامير هاري ليس
بالكبير هناك دعم كبير بالطبع للاسره
المالكه وخاصه الملك تشارلز
وولي عهديها الامير ويليام نحن بنشكرك على
هذه المداخله وطبعا اكيد حنتابع معك
تفاصيل ظهور هاري امام المحكمه شاهد كان
معنا من لندن من امام المحكمه مراسل
العربيه مصطفى زارو شكرا لك
[موسيقى]